hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga my name is liam and something
that you may or may not know about me is
that there's quite a few things that
people don't know about me nobody cares
though because what we want is
information about fictional hunters and
i have just the man boy to examine today
gone freaks you may have heard of him
but trust me you haven't heard of all of
him so today we are going to present 10
fun facts about gun freaks that you did
not know and if you did i don't care
because they're still gonna be fun i
mean this 12 year old little chad lad
looks simple act simple but is anything
but and i don't use the term chad lad
lightly for a preteen gone is quite
shockingly experienced in the uh the
ways of the world and there is a rather
salacious series of facts in here that
will change the way anime only watches c
gone forever but first this video is
sponsored by peervpn the world's most
transparent vpn provider with over 30
million downloads a vpn essentially
changes your ip rerouting internet
traffic through an encrypted tunnel thus
hiding all of your salacious online
activities from prying eyes such as isps
hackers and network administrators pia
is also the most customizable vpn on the
market as well as 100 open source
meaning that the code is public so
anyone can look under the old hood if
desired because when pierre says
transparent they mean transparent pia
works with all major streaming services
be it your netflix your crunchyrolls or
whatever your crazy kids are watching
these days and speaking as someone who
lives in australia a country riddled
with geo-blocking issues because nobody
likes us vpns make me feel like i'm
actually connected to the world around
me that way i can watch series like one
piece in peace buzzfeed offers access to
24 7 customer support so head over to
the link in the description because
currently pia also has a special deal
offering 84 off and four extra months
for free but let us now commence with
gone fun fact number the first which is
that he is a freak like quite literally
his surname freaks definitely strikes a
chord with english speakers however i
think that we more often than not they
give it as some sort of magical japanese
word that we uncultured swine simply do
not understand however the name is
surprisingly simple and derive straight
from the english word freaks it's
slightly different because freaks in
japanese would be pronounced as furikuzu
whilst gone's name is furikusu with an s
sound instead of a zed or a z if you're
american and you probably are but just
know that you're like the only country
that does that it's zed everywhere else
even in canada it said which is that's
crazy but interestingly enough there are
some translations which take this even
more literally such as the malaysian
incarnation where gon's name is and
forgive my pronunciation gon see pelic
which means the weird gone and not to be
left out his first name also has some
meaning attached to it as gone is a
japanese onomatopoeia for hitting
something hitting something like really
hard which i guess sounds like this like
a
gong
no that's like a bell gone gong
or maybe not either way the name really
suits his simple punchy punch cell but
next up we have something that initially
shocked me quite a fair bit which is
that gone is not particularly popular
amongst the hunter hunter fanbase in
fact he's never even won a single hunt
hunter character poll which is unusual
for someone who we would consider to be
a primary protagonist but it does get
worse because not only has gone never
won a character ball which is a double
negative but we're about to make that a
triple because he's never even come
second there have been three official
polls conducted over the lifespan of
hunter hunter and all three of them have
had the exact same medal winners kilauea
in first croppika in second and gone
unceremoniously in third now you might
say hang on internet man third is not
bad in fact it's the opposite of bad
which i believe is good and yeah bronze
medal it's all right i suppose it's
better than anything below it which is
nothing but the real story is told in
the voting numbers in the first
character poll both killer and karapika
received over 13 000 votes each to claim
that first and second place meanwhile
gone was pretty severely trailing in
third with just under 4 000 votes and
you might notice that thirteen thousand
is a slightly bigger number than four
thousand so that's a pretty wide gap and
that trend continued with the second and
third poles and with that in mind it's
not too difficult to see why togashi may
have made the decision to potentially
retire gone from the series and instead
give killer the election arc and krapika
the succession warock and whilst ghan's
popularity is fascinatingly negligible
this sort of thing has happened before
specifically in another yoshihirotakashi
series yu hakusho with its primary
protagonist yusuke mr urameshi managed
to do slightly better than gone
initially by coming second in the first
poll of the series but by the end of its
run yusuke was a solid third place
behind here and karama who just so
happened to be the yu hakusho
counterparts tequila and krapika so
there's a lot of repetition happening
here but that is far from all gone is
most certainly inspired and even follows
a similar general trajectory to
togashi's former protagonist key beats
of both of them include transforming
into black-haired demonic style man
beasts as well as both killing for the
sake of revenge and of course they both
hold green as their trademark color the
difference however is that yusuke
inhabits a more standard shonen world
where this empathy and humanity always
triumphed whereas gone went down he went
in a slightly different bath revealing a
much darker inner nature and in the end
becoming something of a gone monster
meanwhile gone also shares one
similarity to one piece protagonist
monkey d luffy in terms of their
birthday both of whom happen to be born
on the 5th of may which is children's
day in japan however this one single
birthday happens to open up a pretty big
can of controversy because fun fact
number the fourth one is gone's age what
is it and why is it so unbelievably hard
to work out simple answer to the second
question here it's because hunter hunter
is and it's not exactly known for its
flawless continuity in fact the series
has so many flaws that it could probably
just open its own hotel chain but gone's
ages stated at multiple times throughout
the series although some of those should
be taken more seriously than others or
less seriously than others it depends
which time it is for example during the
german election arc he is stated to be
12 however this is probably impossible
chronologically gone is 11 at the time
of the first hunter exam which togashi
states only takes place during january
great so gone became a hunter in january
and then turned 12 the following may we
then have another hunter exam during
greed island which killua participates
in which puts us in january of the next
year and following that the chimera
antarctic ends in august which according
to the mess of dates and days togashi
puts on paper also known as a timeline
that well that would make gone 13
meaning that he cannot possibly be 12
during the chairman election arc this
might seem like splitting his but
togashi is weirdly specific when it
comes to dates and times he has very
clear ideas not so much about what he
wants to happen but definitely when he
wants it to happen which has very much
left this series open to a lot of
inconsistencies like this but for
something that doesn't fit into any
timeline because it never happens let's
now turn to the 1999 anime adaptation
because there are a lot of
shall we say interesting filler scenes
in the 1999 version but this is one of
the more perplexing ones during episode
54 which is the york new city arc there
is a scene of gone and killua in a hotel
room where killua is how shall we say
indulging in some adult content and he
even invites gaunt partake in what
killer himself describes as exciting
programs and he goes on to say that this
is one of the advantages of staying in
cheap hotels since a bit of a killer pro
tip for you there but gone the innocent
young wonderland he is declines this
generous offer from his ever so thirsty
best friend which leads us quite
interestingly into our next fact being
that gone is quite the ladies man
actually i think i've used the word man
very liberally there because he's more
like a like a ladies boy look there are
some parts of hunter hunter that are
more questionable than others hisoka
often comes up due to his his schwing
style urges but another topic that gets
frequently questioned is gone state with
palm given that it doesn't even matter
whether he was 12 or 13 at the time
because it's still still kind of weird
but those instances are just nothing
compared to the manga in chapter 217
after arranging a date with palm guan
and kilwa have a discussion regarding
gon's experience with women at which
point he reveals that there were often
all female crews that made port on whale
island who showed a keen interest in our
minor chad lad and in fact let's quote
gone specifically sometimes ships with
all female crews stopped by whale island
some of them only go out with younger
guys they took me into town and taught
me a lot of stuff they call those types
cougars and while this could be quite
innocent like gone being taken into town
and being taught the ways of chivalry
and fine gentlemanly stuff i mean i
suppose it could be that but the
implications is they're pretty
straightforward so straightforward in
fact that this line was changed in the
2011 anime instead of gone referring to
the women as cougars he labels them as
fanatics which it's still a bit odd but
it does definitely remove some of the
overt sexual connotations and togashi
does have a poignant history with this
topic in some of his other series i mean
the less said about makura from the uh
show manga the better because damn
answer that's a dark story moving
swiftly along to fun fact number
whatever one it is we're up to this one
is all about none abilities or lack
thereof because gone is one of the only
primary secondary perhaps even tertiary
characters in hunter hunter who does not
technically have his own nen ability
when it comes to his jejuncan technique
none of it actually constitutes an
ability each case is just a basic use of
nanby it enhancement transmutation or
emission and the closest he comes to
achieving an actual nern ability would
be briefly transforming into a doggone
but fun fact about the jejuncan
technique its name was a mistake this is
one of my favorite things about gone but
when knuckle asked what his abilities
were called he started whilst trying to
say junken so of course nuncle took this
super seriously and was all i can junken
i like it and so gone just kept it
because that's a gone thing to do but
what i always thought might have been
kind of cool is if gone developed an
ability using his old trademark fishing
rod that could have been quite
interesting but
look it wasn't meant to be instead
togashi chose to focus on hand-to-hand
combat which brings us to the topic of
arms which hands are generally attached
to now you may or may not have noticed
over the course of hunt hunter but god
has this very handy motif being that
something generally bad tends to happen
to one of his arms in any given arc
during the hunter exam his arm was
broken by hanzo during heaven's arena an
arm was broken by guido then in york new
city gone was subject to nobunaga's
brutal arm-based wrestling moving on
into greed islanders the whole chunk of
arm was just plain blown off by genthru
and then of course in the chimera
antarctic pito's post mortem then
severed an entire arm or at least large
majority of an arm was more armed than
had previously been severed i guess is
the point so it's a rather painful motif
to adopt and speaking of adopted gon was
adopted by his aunt mito however he does
still very much take after his father
jing although this only really becomes
clear during the chimera antarctic
whilst gone was in his sulky rage mode
his general intelligence skyrocketed and
all of a sudden he was capable of making
jin level calculations regarding the
actions of those around him in fact
there was one particular moment where
gone was using just pure leverage to
halt two of the royal guard in their
tracks gone didn't actually have the
power to defeat either of them but he
understood the situation around him and
played it perfectly to his advantage so
as simple as he may appear when it comes
to numbers there is a pretty terrifying
level of mental potential residing
within yangon also as our next point of
interest gone has a close childhood
friend that we never got to know sort of
like krapika and pyro just without the
whole being brutally slaughtered thing
on whale island gone was good friends
with a girl named noko who we see very
briefly seeing him off at the port which
interestingly in the manga noko is
smiling when gone departs whereas in the
2011 anime she is crying so they were
really taking every opportunity to flush
out some fairly insignificant characters
there which is nice i like that and gone
even mentions noko when he takes killua
back to whale island to visit but the
very fact that she ever gets mentioned
at all shows that togashi may have had
some plans for her at some stage and
that she was perhaps just another
character who got forgotten about in a
grand process of improvisational manga
sort of like say leorio but something we
should not forget about is to watch this
next video it's also about hunter hunter
because there's always more to learn
explore and experience with this
wonderful series so i look forward to
seeing you there